Of course my good friend
Andy Richter is here.
Hi Andy.
Hi Conan.
How are you?
I'm doing pretty well.
I'm glad to see,
this makes a big difference,
you know, we took a page
from major league sports.
Yeah.
And we got
our fans to send in cardboard cutouts.
[Andy] Yeah.
We got so many,
and thousands and thousands of people
sent in pictures,
we printed them out
and we put them here,
to give us a packed audience.
[Andy] Yeah.
Gotta tell you,
maybe it's cause it's a Monday,
they seem a little low energy right now.
Yeah.
It's, yeah.
They're not, they don't have the same pep.
[Conan] No.
The same,
two dimensional pep
that they did last week.
Yeah,
no, they seem a little flat.
Now normally we have an audience warmup,
and I think they could use one right now.
I think,
maybe Andy you could help me
whip this crowd
into a frenzy.
Any thoughts?
Sure, sure.
I actually have just the thing,
if you don't mind.
Yeah, not at all.
Andy Rector now,
is going to warm up
our cardboard audience,
get them excited.
What do you got there?
All right.
Who wants a T shirt?
Yeah.
Oh man, this thing got some juice.
[Conan] Yeah, try one.
Here you go.
How about you Comey?
(gun explodes)
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
What about one of you Kevin Hart?
(gun explodes)
Oh, sorry lady.
I was trying for Kevin Hart.
(upbeat music)
(gun explodes)
(laughing)
[Conan] Oh.
Hey look,
you hit one Kevin Hart
and you knocked down three of them.
[Andy] That's the way it goes.
Hey, you know what,
get one of these guys
who's being a wise ass.
Find someone who's being
kind of a wise ass.
Let's see.
[Conan] Oh my God.
Look at this guy right here.
[Conan] Yeah.
Hey, why no smile buddy?
(gun explodes)
(laughing)
They're picking up Andy,
I can feel the energy rising.
They're pretty happy now,
right Reverend?
(gun explodes)
(laughing)
Yeah.
I still wanna try and get Comey good.
(gun explodes)
Oh, you've got to get Comey.
He has to pay for his.
Yeah, what about our emails now?
(gun explodes)
Boom, yes,
there he goes.
(clapping)
Justice.
(upbeat music)
[Conan] Don't act.
How about this guy?
Don't act like I don't see you Kevin Hart.
(upbeat music)
[Conan] Wait,
he actually.
(laughing)
[Andy] He stood back up.
You stood him back up.
I think they're pretty pumped now.
(Clapping)
[Conan] Nice job, Andy.
I know I am.
[Conan] Nice job.
Man, man.
It's like fun as I've had in awhile.
Well, sorry Kevin.
Seriously, sorry buddy.
Well that's how we repay fans
that take the time to
send us their photos.
(laughing)
We blast them in the face
with a T shirt cannon
at close range.
They got T shirts out of the deal.
That may look,
unfriendly,
but I promise you
every fan that was hit
we're gonna send them
a photograph of the T shirt.
(laughing)
And then they can have it
made into a cardboard cutout.
A cardboard cutout of a T shirt.
[Conan] Yeah.